how's it going there reject nation we're
going to watch gravity falls today
everyone's like it gets good around
episode 19 or something yeah
it's always in the future power through
guys let's go to season two enjoying the
show
if you can't hit that like button that
would be amazeballs also subscribe and
click the notification bell get notified
when our reaction for the next g falls
is up here on the channel full length
watch logs for this show as always over
at our patreon page you say this for the
new people so you can skip this if
you've already heard it covered a bunch
of shows over there as well thanks to
all who have joined already and the boys
at prepper our hearts fall like gravity
for you in a positive way let's do this
a frog taught me how to cross the street
but my house is haunted oh lord out here
goes
this thing taught me how to dance
i've been chicken for seven days
straight uh zeus
hoedown hero
i
i love arcades i miss arcades ooh
cutscene dr karate you killed my father
again
[Music]
winners don't lose it's my new mantra
wendy
what's up babe yeah just putting up some
flyers for my band look how bad he looks
we just started this round whoa oh hey
relax man i'm just trying to spend a
little time with my girlfriend all right
it'll just be one round
poor dipper oh cool cool watch out yeah
so threatened murder ham
go trail on a training montage i want
dipper to get buff
dude i think i'm picking up a radio
station inside my head oh
i'll handle it
conflict
it wendy
wendy come on out girl come on down you
realize she's not here right she's not a
dog
hey here's an idea why don't i call her
right now and see if she wants to go out
on a date with you hey look don't you
you don't have to oh don't please man
what are you gonna do huh wendy has a
really long number this is
i'll buy you a new one oh no you're not
getting off that easy
hey i know a fight when i see one stay
right there
you me circle park three o'clock ah he's
gone i was just gonna call the boys over
to blaze a few bets the smart money's on
skinny jeans
of course it is robbie's like twice my
size i mean what would getting myself
killed accomplished buy a gun
this day will never end relax dipper
just try not to think about robbie
hiding from robbie unable to face his
fears
fears are for chumps that's why i don't
have any oh we'll see about that you
know studies show that keeping a ladder
inside the house is more dangerous than
a loaded gun that's why i own 10 guns
why are you acting so cray-cray you're
the one who's acting cray-cray
i gotta go now why would uncle stan be
so weirded out by ladders
they're bad luck to walk under i think
he has a secret fear of heights
we'll have to test him to be sure or we
could leave well enough alone
nah
the game is on the movie basically i
don't know what it'll be like to go
inside a video game for real is that
what's gonna happen this
episode it's years ago
[Applause]
in the computer
a winner never runs away from a fight
that's easy for you to say you have more
than one life and the biggest muscles i
wish one of these guys could fight
robbie is that what's gonna happen this
episode
ultimate power
back back hold forward back forward down
hold quarter circle forward triple punch
what have you done i guess it didn't
work
uh
zeus
select your character
[Music]
pixels are really sharp
greetings
[Laughter]
oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
there's a great uncle's day yeah of
course it's not a day i made up
are you saying these heels are too high
do they make you uncomfortable hmm
maybe admit it admit you have a fear of
heights what that's why you bought me
these you should be ashamed of yourself
and on great uncle's day no let
so i have a fear of heights is that
really so cray-cray
no
no i must defeat the world's greatest
fight fighters take me to the soviet
union oh no wow
maximum power his name is robbie v and
he's kind of like my arch enemy
did he kill your father
and he posts a really annoying amount of
status updates and then he killed your
father
sure
anyway i was hoping you could you know
scare him off for me so i don't have to
fight the guy
your question makes my shoulders bounce
uppercut countertop full of cards yes
challenge accepted press start
[Music]
uh-oh i think i hear my uncle stay
perfectly still
i said stay still this is as still as i
can stay
how am i gonna get grunkle stan over his
fear of heights
hey mabel have you met rumble yet
mabel he's not a toy he's a fighting
machine i'm gonna get him to defend me
from robbie isn't that kind of like
cheating i guess so
well i'll see you after the fight
tell me my opponent's special oh the
music give him a good scare yes
oh no
you're not planning on taking me
somewhere super high up are you grunkle
stan i would never
[Music]
this happens to be the greatest warrior
that ever lived yeah right hey eyepatch
what did the kid promise you more tape
for your forearms
how can you laugh when you killed this
boy's father wait what
[Laughter]
what is happening i didn't want to have
to do this man but you gave me no choice
maybe now you won't mess with me
oh no
i think robbie's had enough
oh sharokina
oh my god damn that guy's crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
what the heck was that you were only
supposed to scare him you almost killed
him i will not rest until the man who
dishonored you is destroyed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this is my favorite episode
it'll never get better
donkey kong
the barrels is great please rumble you
gotta stop
[Music]
i love this
you might get a cramp
ah
there's a great bonus level
[Music]
how'd he get him
that's pretty much what i was expecting
you're doing better than i thought now
let go of the handrail
hey robbie get your own water towers
shhh keep it down he'll find us
challenge your sideard
no no no oh no
oh no
no no don't don't finish me
rumble
robbie didn't kill my father
and who did what no one did i i lied to
you
then you're actually a bad guy
i guess i kind of am
charming
cutscene
not to join the path of evil the boy has
led me astray from my teachings if
robbie v is not the last stage then it
must be
i started all this and i've got to at
least try to stop it you sure you
wouldn't rather hide like a wimp
fight like a man it is
you done grown dipper
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no you'll fight like a girl who was
also a baby
[Music]
uppercut
that was worth a shot
hear the story gravity falls
oh no
what
what should i do roll them up and put
them on my wall dude we should rock
paper scissors for him
whoa
wow ultimate
power power
it's mabel showdown
smart i survived and i feel great wait
let me do a cocky dance just to be sure
it's not even worth it
play lead guitar so i gotta save my
hands
wendy you're back yeah man whoa what the
heck happened here freak tornado or
something uh well
uh that's wendy's family cool
really makes me happy to see my two boys
hanging out oh
[Music]
did you hear that she called me one of
her two boys
we stay at each other's throats we'll
both lose wendy we need to make a cold
war pact okay what's that we need to
learn to just hate each other in silence
[Laughter]
good one wendy that's great oh man just
a second
[Music]
oh yeah
i have shorts and determinations
it's a me a maple
oh even my friends i hope that's not
true live your best life suits that's my
favorite episode to ruin it
it's canon don't worry
it's it actually happened
ah yes that episode was like perfectly
suited
to me and me alone
no one else enjoyed this episode in the
world this is the lowest rated one
only greg liked this one yeah what was
this about i didn't get the reference oh
dude it was so fun
if you don't play if you know him play
like 90s 80s 90s arcades this will
probably fly over your head in so many
ways
um
but beyond that i just thought i thought
it was actually really good storytelling
you know even when it came to i want to
talk about the main stuff obviously but
when it came to grunkle stan and maple
with the heights uh when we were coming
back to that i'm like this is enjoyable
and i like this because i have a major
fear of heights uh but i was like how is
even gonna come together
like was usually their beast sometimes
their b stories are just so off to the
side
and i like that it actually
culminated together in the end i was
like oh that's that's pretty clever how
that actually uh came to fruition that
way
um but yeah i mean just the the comedy
alone of
all the references they did to the 90s
arcades obviously mainly riffing on
street fighter but you know they got
their donkey kong references they got
their trons they got i got a whole bunch
of it's a mortal kombat song yeah yeah
yeah and they even stay true to the
music the only thing they could have
done is uh on those cut scenes at the
end is have like subtitles up here yeah
instead of them talking to him yeah yeah
because that's usually what it was was
like terrible subtitles with no mouth
movement yeah um but still it was still
like a really it was like pretty much in
your perfect episode and then
uh this whole thing with like dipper and
robbie uh their rivalry that's been
building up their feud and then how
uh dipper ultimately learns to stand up
for himself and take the beating you
know is is pretty cool like he doesn't
just walk out of there and outsmart it
and win i like that the show allowed him
to actually his ass whooped yeah that
was the key to solving it you know and
then it allowed him to confront robbie
and stand up to him as well so i i just
think that the way they did all
everything was just firing on all
cylinders their b story complemented the
a story really well
um you know dipper's learning lesson was
great and then the comedy of um mr
rumble fist i keep calling ken in my
head
yeah yeah something like that uh is it's
the name of the episode i actually don't
know the name of this um
is the name of the character
tan
just call firefighter okay yeah but
either way no it was still pretty uh it
was still a pretty near perfect episode
to me
in every way so yeah i know
i kind of covered the whole show there
john so take it away
i've done the same to you yeah
no no yeah absolutely i thought this was
super delightful and uh i love the way
that yeah the the fun whimsical
aspect of the episode is also perfectly
ingrained like you said with the story
and the fact that he doesn't even you
know like learn to fight he doesn't do
any of that stuff he just accepts his
position and sees you know kind of from
the outside and then it's like yeah i'm
not gonna win this so i'll just take my
knocks and be on my way and so yeah this
was like a really well engaged episode
and even like the sea story was zeus i
like how that kind of complimented he's
literally inside a video game while
dipper has one come to life in the real
world
and uh yeah like even though it's so
specifically referencing video games and
and that era of video games it still
fits i think well within the strange
x-files twilight zone that gravity falls
itself sort of
exists as even though those you know
like a fighting video game isn't the
first thing i think of when i think of
like weird sci-fi occurrences but i love
the way they brought that in and like
you said tied that into the uh the
grunkle stan plot line giving him the
final boost to like i i love the way
they were displaced in time him and
mabel because you know for her this is
like an initial trauma and for him this
is exposure therapy happening all at the
same time and uh and yeah even with
robbie like i thought they gave robbie
more
of a flesh you know even though he's
pretty much you know like the same
character we've always known him to be i
thought having wendy be removed from the
equation and zeroing in on this conflict
was actually a nice choice because i
feel like you know it'll probably still
persist in some way or another but i
feel like a lot of shows would maybe
just let that be just kind of an always
recurring detail without ever zooming
too close or too far away from it so uh
yeah i liked what they did as like a you
know ensemble piece as much as you know
like a fun video game riff
well i think the the way they
managed to not lock themselves only into
street fighter reference even though the
character they're pulling from is
clearly from there and while i did some
more street fighter references like with
the bonus round with the car i thought
it was cool to when they're like walking
the streets and the way they like when
when uh rumble is like unleashed and
he's walking the streets and doing stuff
it's kind of like those uh the ninja
turtles simpsons arcade yeah side
scrolling yeah kind of like walk up and
down and pick this up and then yeah go
to the next screen yeah for sure um and
you know it's like in a day and age the
two things here that i want to say is
like in a day and age where you have
like animated stuff properties like
wreck-it ralph for example that can hop
into the arcade world it was cool to see
it blended here in a way that really
honored like they in wreck-it ralph
they've even had like ryu in the
background but they don't use them yeah
or like you see him on frame but they
don't really use him and here you get a
really like utilize it because it's
animated form and they use the full
fruition and the other thing too is that
um
you know we've been watching the show
all of us are dead which deals heavily
with bullying yeah so to see a an
episode where the bully decides not to
take the bunch which is kind of
refreshing yeah just a personal note
like oh this is kind of nice actually
yeah yeah yeah then it creates like a
fun
new dynamic based on the same dynamic
with them to go forward yeah so it's
great guys this is this is awesome uh
and do we do clarify if you're watching
to this point is that wendy's family the
big lumberjack do you think that's what
they were referencing yeah i was like i
didn't know if we'd ever established
that before and i guess i should have
thought about it but uh she's got a
happy family yeah they are all red yes
but yeah guys leave your thoughts down
below thanks for so much for being here
subscribe and leave that like button and
uh hey let's do a page
tyler hey this would have been a good
one for every pixel my bakery should
have waited but tyler hague is another
perfect choice for this because there's
anyone on our patreon page for sure who
would love to immerse themselves to the
point where they can bring video game
characters to life or hop into a video
game it is our game guru tyler haye
since the first time we ever got to know
this gentleman he's always been vastly
obsessed with video games
oftentimes we would do like google
hangouts he would have like five this is
true he would have like five different
screens playing at the same time usually
one of them being a video game
so the guy's an absorption machine he
really knows the stuff he even a couple
years ago helped me get a ps4 so when i
think of who at our patreon page is the
most game enthusiast it will be you my
friend thank you so much for being here
for so long man you're loyal like no
one's business and uh i hope one day
you can't have a video game character to
come to life absolutely you're our seuss
buddy you can even put yourself inside
of a video game crawl inside one of
those screens man make it happen
love you buddy
[Music]
you